this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice
ramsey personality george camel is my
co-host today on a special eve of
thanksgiving thanksgiving eve
show
which means that um
we have different rules today
um we are um
we are really sure that gratitude is an
indication of your future prosperity
people who are ungrateful entitled
arrogant little twits tend to not
prosper they tend to be selfish
self-centered and people who are
grateful who are
kind who are who are thinking of others
they have a tendency to prosper because
the grateful people tend to be the
content people they tend to be the
people who
think of others as i said they tend to
be generous their faces reflect it
they're different people you make
decisions differently when you have a
spirit of gratitude that's what it comes
down to and if you're discontent you're
going to make decisions out of that
discontentment
so we're just we're people that believe
that corny stuff to be true
uh pretty much straight up corn balls
and proud of it part of our brand
sarcastic corn balls that's a good one
for us yeah that's us so uh but we're
that and so uh if you call in today to
be on the air you have to pay to be on
the air today
uh and your your ticket price is you
have to tell us what you're grateful for
because you have by god ought to be
grateful for something if you can't
think of something you maybe not don't
you shouldn't you shouldn't call today
because we're going to be like we're
going to be cornballs we want to know
gratitude
so we did this with our team this
morning but um there was a lady in prior
to the civil war named sarah hale
sarah was an editor of a huge magazine
150 000 subscribers which in those days
was a lot of people high percentage of
the population
and um she had written she'd written a
bunch of famous things she wrote the
nursery rhyme mary had a little lamb a
classic classic yep and so sarah was
quite a famous person in her day and she
had written to the president of the
united states 30 consecutive years
wow with one request requesting that he
set aside
a national day of thanksgiving where we
stop and give thanks to the lord finally
at 74 years old in september 28th of
1863 she wrote another letter to then
sitting president
abraham lincoln
who got with his
secretary of state um william seward who
was a known wordsmith uh fabulous writer
brilliant man
and uh had him write the proclamation
that became
thanksgiving day
october 3rd
1863 a proclamation the president united
states this the year
that is drawing towards its close has
been filled with the blessings of
fruitful fields and healthful skies to
these bounties which are so constantly
enjoyed that we are prone to forget the
source from which they come others have
been added which are so of so
extraordinary in nature that they cannot
fail to penetrate and soften even the
heart which is habitually insensitive to
the ever watchful providence
of almighty god
in the midst of a civil war of unequaled
magnitude and severity which is
sometimes seemed to foreign states to
invite and to provoke their aggression
peace has been preserved with all
nations order has been maintained the
laws have been respected and obeyed and
harmony has prevailed everywhere except
in the theater of military conflict
while that theater has been greatly
contracted by the advancing armies and
navies of the union needful diversions
of wealth and of strength from the
fields of peaceful industry to the
national defense have not arrested the
plow the shuttle or the ship the axe has
enlarged the borders of our settlements
and the minds as well of iron and coal
as of the precious metals have yielded
even more abundantly than heretofore
population is steadily increased
notwithstanding the waste that has been
made in the camp the siege and the
battlefield
and the country rejoicing in the
consciousness of augmented strength and
vigor is permitted to expect continuance
of years with large increase
of freedom
no human counsel hath devised nor hath
any mortal hand worked out these great
things
they are the gracious gifts of the most
high god
who while dealing with us in anger for
our sins hath nevertheless remembered
mercy
it has seemed fit to me and proper that
they should be solemnly reverently and
gratefully acknowledged as with one
heart and one voice by the whole
american people
i do therefore invite my fellow citizens
in every part of the united states and
also those who are at sea and those who
are adjourning in foreign lands to set
apart and observe the last thursday of
november next as a day of thanksgiving
and praise to our beneficent father
who dwelleth in the heavens
and i recommend to them that while
offering up ascriptions justly due to
him
for such singular deliverances and
blessings they also with humble pentax
for our national perverseness and
disobedience commend to his tender care
all those who have become widows orphans
mourners or sufferers in the lamentable
strife in which we are unavoidably
engaged and fervently implore the
interposition of the almighty hand
to heal
the wounds of the nation
and to restore it as soon as may be
consistent with the divine purposes to
the full enjoyment of peace
harmony
tranquility and union
and testimony aware of i have hereto
set my hand and caused the seal of the
united states to be affixed done at the
city of washington this third day of
october in the year of our lord one
thousand
eighteen hundred and sixty-three
president abraham lincoln william seward
secretary of state
been a long time
since uh
we had a president of the united states
say so blatantly boldly and up front
that it is god
from where our blessings flow
been too long and um i mean
they may have i may have missed it but i
don't think i did
all of the
garbage and the infighting
and the
politicized
garbage and and toxicity that's out
there now
don't we need leaders like this now
man
i either party would be be happy with
either parties they'd stand up and do
that right there
and said it like that and eloquently
well i mean yeah
no one speaks like that anymore but um
it's just beautiful pros
but the uh
the idea i mean
that that we let me just tell you if you
were confused that is the actual
proclamation i just read from the united
states president that the purpose of
thanksgiving day
is to say thank you to the lord
for his blessings
you may not like that you may not
have done that if it was you
but that is what's known as a fact
and facts are interesting things to have
knowledge of
that has actually occurred that is the
genesis of this
holiday
it's not something else it wasn't
invented
as the day before black friday
it was invented when we stop and say
thank you lord because you blessed us
beyond our wildest imaginations
it's a thanksgiving eve show here on the
ramsey show george campbell ramsey
personality is my co-host
thanks for joining us
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at zip
recruiter have made the whole job search
way easier ziprecruiter is rated the
number one job site in the us by g2 and
it's free so how does it work first go
to ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile
they can personally invite you to apply
for the job so if you're ready for an
easier job search check out ziprecruiter
sign up for free right now at
ziprecruiter.com
ken that's ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
[Applause]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today host of the fine print the
final episode for season one there's
been ten episodes total uh on ramsey
networks has dropped it's all about the
robin hood app i listened to the rest of
it this morning very very interesting
very well done george thanks for
listening good to have you it was a fun
episode to do very i learned a lot just
doing these episodes yeah you do a lot
of digging yeah it's very i mean the
detail is pretty incredible so as you
call in today what are you thankful for
brian in salt lake city what are you
thankful for
i'm not ready
hey dave i am thankful that god sent his
only son jesus christ to die for me and
everybody else who believes in him that
we may have eternal life very well done
okay how can we help today
i am calling because i want to know how
long it is okay to
not put money towards retirement to save
for a down payment
in my case i'm projecting it would take
me three years to save for a house down
payment if i don't put anything in
retirement and seven years if i do put
the 15 towards the raw retirement
options
three years is about as far as i like to
go george yeah i'm i'm in the same boat
two to three years if you're going
gazelle intense saving up for that down
payment any longer than that and i would
start to look at maybe a mix of those
two things so that you're not
losing out on on that investing for too
long of a time yeah if you told me four
years i'd probably tell you to do
something towards retirement and make it
five years but uh uh but in this case
you can just roll up your sleeves and
knock it out in three hey that's what i
would do i would have at it good job man
good job
paul is in sacramento california paul
what are you thankful for
well i am thankful for
growing up in a christian
family it's cool that you know i
wouldn't guess
smack around in life
without having god by my side amen cool
how can we help today
um so i've got a question about
for you actually about real estate or
becoming a realtor
and
sorry i'm a little nervous
so
you endorse
your realtors and
i know your ads always say like don't go
for a newbie and all that which i
completely agree with
and
i want to know the steps to become
a realtor and one day
endorsed
okay
all right so you're not a real estate
agent today
no i'm working on it at the moment okay
good
good how old are you
i'm 19. okay cool
well i got my license when i was 18
years old in 1978 and i sold real estate
while i was in college
which was a bit of a stretch it was hard
interest rates were very high and i was
very young and very stupid
and it was very difficult but i sold
some houses and made more money than i
would have made flopping whoppers you
know so it was good experience in that
regard
so what is your plan to enter that
difficult market at your age what's your
what's your thinking on that
i really don't know that's why i'm
calling
okay what's driving you to want to be a
realtor
well i've pretty much been around real
estate my whole life my parents weren't
realtors but
they bought and
sold houses all the time
and i've just
been around my whole life i love it
so you may already have a little bit of
knowledge which is great and once you
get your license and you start you know
you sell the first house obviously it's
going to take some time to get that
experience but you start to do that and
you start to create some of that word of
mouth uh referrals and you maybe get in
with a firm and dave you can speak to
this from your extensive real estate
background but as a young guy getting
started how do you get to the point
where you have that trust and
credibility you know when i was starting
paul there weren't people doing like
they do today it was pretty much just
lone ranger everybody was today there
are some of the top performing real
estate agents for instance some of our
elps
they have a team of real estate agents
uh you may have a a key person that's
out front and they may have a buyer's
agent a couple of listing agents and a
couple of people who just work for them
that are licensed that show houses and
do other things to get just to keep
things moving and this may be a person
that sells 300 houses a year and they
may have a three or four person team uh
that stuff did wasn't around when i was
doing it at your age um and if i was uh
gonna tell somebody what to do i would
tell you to join a team like that
come in almost as an intern into a team
of high performers and go in there and
work for someone
rather than out there on your own in the
cold so to speak and you'll learn what
it what the rhythm is of somebody who's
a high producer of a team that's really
high octane
versus trying to gut it out and you know
get enough dirt under your fingernails
to figure it all out you can gut your
way through it eventually grind your way
through it but i think the shortest path
the easiest path would be to you know
if you cannot if you can play toss with
peyton manning uh it's better than just
going out in the backyard and throwing
the ball up in the air and catching it
yourself you know i mean that's kind of
the way it feels so so get in there and
with a group that is running at a very
high clip
and that'll teach you to run at that
speed
i'll teach you to throw a ball with that
speed catch a ball with that speed get
the deal done uh and the way their minds
think the way their spirits operate
because it's different when you're a
high performer like that because the
vast majority of real estate agents um
don't sell three houses a year
the vast majority i i forget the number
of it's like 70 80 percent of them wow
and so most people with real estate
licenses really don't make a living in
the real estate business um you know so
there's very few that do and that's why
we always tell people to deal only with
a high octane high protein high producer
but i think it's a you know you've got
the
the problem
it can it can be overcome but you've got
the legitimate barrier of
getting someone to trust a 19 year old's
opinion about their three or four
hundred thousand dollar purchase
that's just tough that's a hard one
can it be done yeah i did it
i did it it went through 400 000 back
then you know that that
be a lot less but obviously a lot of
inflation in the last 40 years but
anyway bottom line is that's what i
would do good question thank you for
joining us stephanie is in salem oregon
stephanie what are you thankful for
hi dave hi george i'm i'm super grateful
for my family we're going to be having
our first thanksgiving uh dinner
tomorrow is like a big family
in the last couple years due to covid so
i'm super grateful for it yeah
a lot of people getting back to the
turkey after kova that's good yeah i
like that yeah very good for sure how
can we help today
so i have um a burning question for you
so my husband and i are in baby steps
four through six and got free got our
emergency fund
now it's time to get on the 15 percent
and a little bit confused i literally
have been binge listening to you for the
last 20 months i'm still tell it working
from home
um and i have not heard this question
answered um so we need to do the 15
i work for the state
and so they automatically take six
percent out um and like invest it into
a plan
but i still need to take my additional
um nine percent yeah nine percent and
then my husband
we also need to do like his 15
so my question is
um
with the state you get offered a 457 and
you can do that into a roth
and the maximum is 19 500 a year that i
can put into that
um
for my husband
he does not have a 401k through his work
so we've been doing a roth for him
but do i take the additional
once he maxes out his roth do i take his
additional amount and put it into my 457
plan or does he open up his own
um individual like retirement like
brokerage account for his remaining
amount
um that's where i'm a little bit
okay there's not a his and hers it's 15
of your household income
and that number we've got that number
we've got to run through
the paradigm of what to put it in if
you've got a 401k at the state that'll
be better than a 457 if not the 457's
okay that's just deferred comp as all
457 is
so the the rule of thumb george's match
beats
match is going to beat the roth and roth
is going to be traditional so do as much
as you can where there's a match
then do as much as you can where there's
a roth whether it's at the state or
whether it's an individual roth and if
you run out there and you still haven't
used up to 15 of your household income
then do traditional but it doesn't
matter who's it sitting in
run it down through that paradigm for
the whole household
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
[Music]
it's the eve of thanksgiving
thanksgiving eve george campbell ramsey
personality is my co-host today quite a
little crowd has showed up here on their
way to grandmother's house
i dropped by to have a cup of coffee and
some free cookies at the
old ramsey solutions lobby also on the
debt free stage here
ready to do a debt-free scream dominique
is with us hi dominique how are you hi
guys how are y'all better than we
deserve what are you thankful for today
i am thankful for the program that you
have given america and the whole world i
really am i appreciate y'all so much
that's exactly how we told you to say it
well done
that's great thank you darling we
appreciate that how much have you paid
off 30
462 dollars and 64 cents i love it and
how long did it take
nine months four weeks and one day cool
and um
like 10 months okay pretty much and
what was your range of income during
that 10 minutes um i went from about 60
000 to 67 000. cool what do you do for a
living i am a uh-60 blackhawk helicopter
technical inspector whoa
okay
wow
and uh what kind of debt was this thirty
thousand bucks uh some of it was a tsp
loan um car loan
trailer a car trailer that my ex-husband
bought and uh lawyer fees
okay a car trailer because you got to
have one of those to carry your car when
race cars are life yeah yeah i hear you
okay
so your military obviously thank you for
your service thank you and so blackhawk
here at clarksville
no i work in san antonio oh okay for the
texas army national guard okay all right
excellent very cool well we've got a
bunch of blackhawks up the road up here
so that's what i was thinking right
above us here there's a
101st and so on up at clarksville
section i know those guys well yeah i
bet you do cool very cool so the debt
the 30 000 in debt was what now it was a
car loan 16 000 oh in the car trailer
the car trailer of course the tsp loan
that i used to buy a single wide
trailer
and uh lawyers fees so that's how the
single watch paid off it i paid it off
so you are 100 debt free totally
debt-free your house and everything
absolutely okay good for you
very cool well done
okay so what happened uh 10 months ago
or so that put you on this ramsay stuff
so it was the middle of summer during
covid of course and i have two little
girls
by myself
and they were stir crazy
and i was trying to find a place to take
them to go swimming to get them out of
the house to get moving we were going
hiking
and then one saturday morning somebody
knocks on my front door
with um court papers
i was served in a lawsuit for 32
thousand dollars for a truck that was
awarded to my ex-husband that i thought
he had taken care of
and i fell apart
i had heard about you
back in 2014 when i first came off
active duty and i was going to follow
the plan and then
my ex-husband kind of derailed it he
didn't want to do exactly what dave said
he didn't want to follow
good choices and so i let myself get
off the good path and uh we bought a
house the totally stupid way zero down
va loan under water like you wouldn't
believe
it got flooded by hurricane harvey i
didn't have flood insurance i went
through every bad thing that you can
imagine
[Music]
and finally i decided this is enough
they want more money than i paid for my
car and my house put together
and i didn't have it
so i found a lawyer that was willing to
help me fight back
and
i decided i was going to dig out
because i want better for my girls than
i ever imagined i could have for myself
so how much did you end up paying on the
car repo from him when he took the truck
according to the divorce decree nothing
oh you got out of it the lawyer's fees
were all i paid on that
wow
wow good job lawyers yeah i'm so
thankful for him yeah they did a good
job because you don't usually win those
no so uh you must have had an angle on
that good job very cool good good good
good wow so you've been through a lot
this last well you're just a resilient
person
i don't want to get in your way don't
pray for strength okay because god
doesn't have anything to make you
stronger well it's one thing to not have
a spouse on board but to have an
ex-spouse who's not on board that makes
things a whole lot more tricky yeah and
you navigated this stuff while clawing
your way out of debt and with an amazing
why
those two girls sitting over there was
that what drove you on this journey
absolutely because i know that
everything i do is an example for them
and they're going to want to walk the
same footsteps i walk and i want to get
as far as i can so they can go further
yeah
they see their mom as a fighter
so you cleaned up all the remaining mess
from the divorce
the portion that was yours ran off the
uh
the car company that did the repo on the
x that had your name on it too
uh but were able to get rid of that with
a legal maneuver and uh then you plow
your way through 30 000 bucks in 10
months absolutely and that means you
were on beans and rice or did you sell
something no i mean i every stimulus
penny i got went towards it i had i had
money in savings because i was going to
redo the front porch of my trailer
because it was falling apart
and thank god my my parents came up one
weekend and my dad went to the lumber
store and he bought the lumber
installed it all for me and he was like
use that money and help dig yourself out
yeah cool how much was that
um i don't know the money and savings i
mean oh that was
four or five thousand okay all right and
then the rest of the other 25 000 or so
you just plowed through absolutely
extra i did i already worked two jobs as
it is because i'm a dual status
technician i'm a civilian for the dod
during the week and i'm a guards member
on the weekends okay and so i couldn't
take on a third job but i just i i did
everything extra i could yeah every time
they let you turn every time they let
you in there you went absolutely so
phenomenal well done what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
intentionality know your goal and
don't take your eyes off of it
just keep moving yeah that's definitely
you
and i mean i could have gotten out of it
a lot quicker but um i had to i had to
be intentional with my girls too so
every uh every month i plan one monday a
month where i pick one of them up early
and we have one-on-one time and i focus
on just them for their mental health and
so yeah we spent a little bit of extra
money that we probably could have used
towards debt but it was more important
yeah there's not much room in these
numbers you were on beans and rice i
mean
that personal time is like walking
through a park or something i mean you
weren't you weren't spending serious
money
well yeah yeah there you go well done
very very well done did you have any
cheerleaders along the way it sounds
like your dad for sure both my parents
um my bonus mom my ex-mother-in-law
um my commander at work he's actually a
ramsay coordinator which i didn't know
until i was kind of in the middle of
digging
um just everybody my friends my people
at church it was great yeah wow well
that helps a lot all of a sudden people
start coming around you and you as soon
as you start moving in the right
direction and it accelerates the process
because it gives you energy oh yes and
because you get tired while you're
plowing through this uh for 10 freaking
months
9 months 4 weeks and 32 minutes yeah i
mean wow
pretty incredible pretty incredible well
done well we're going to do something
today you're the very first person we've
done this with
we're going to give you a copy of the
brand new book that comes out in january
we're going to give you an early release
copy of baby steps millionaires thank
you because we think that's what you're
going to be next that's the next chapter
in your story i'll also give you a copy
of the total money makeover and that
will
be for you to pay it forward and run
into somebody else who's had it
they reach the end when you finally say
i've had it when they knock on the door
and they serve that lawsuit you go
that's it i'm done i'm not living like
this anymore and you brought the two
kiddos with you and oh great t-shirts
what are their names in a just let's get
them up there teagan is ten and alana is
nine all right tegan and alana why one
and why two absolutely sing one and
thing two i love it
[Laughter]
they are my why yes that's very good i
love that that might be at first i don't
think i've seen that one before i don't
haven't seen that t-shirt very creative
so but it's very very good and uh
beautiful young ladies so very very cool
lots of good reasons to fight scratch
claw and win right there
all right dominique tegan and alana san
antonio texas 30 000
paid off in 10 months making 60 to 67.
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two
one we're debt-free
i
love it
[Applause]
are those tears of joy i hope so single
mom she pulled it off incredible that's
how you do it right there no excuses
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today guys christmas countdown
is on they didn't move it christmas this
year is in december
and a christmas frame of mind goes with
thanksgiving eve and we like celebrating
around here as we've already established
we celebrate christmas with our ramsey
show listeners by giving away money the
ramsey christmas cash giveaway it's
become a tradition
every week we are giving away 500 up
through christmas we've already given
away some
and the grand prize of five thousand
bucks and you can enter to win every day
increase your chances of winning no
purchase necessary go to ramsey
solutions dot com slash giveaway plus if
you're looking for life-changing gifts
for your family and friends our famous
week-long black friday sale well we're
right in the middle of it this week only
you can get up to 73 off best sellers
that will make perfect gifts for him
her
kids of all ages yeah we got everything
including 10 sale on a bunch of the
books including the total money makeover
it's all there
forget the one-time use presents get a
lifetime of hope for someone shop our
black friday sale
online store
ramsey solutions
dot com kevin's in boise hi kevin
welcome to the ramsay show
okay hello sir how are you better than i
deserve what's up in your world
hey and question i was trying to find
out
when you
instead of seeing a
smart investor pro at what point do you
buy
a property for a rental income
versus investing it versus you know to a
investor pro
okay well we won't i wouldn't suggest
you start buying rental property unless
you pay cash for it after your home is
paid off
and so you've got if you're using ramsey
lingo that would be in baby step seven
then yeah kevin where are you at
financially do you have a paid for house
currently
yes okay
yeah we we have zero debt we have
nothing way to go that's amazing
yeah i would begin right now to pile up
some money as fast as i could to pay
cash for my first rental if i was you
and i think meanwhile you could probably
save 15 of your income still
uh towards towards mutual funds that's
the way i did it
i i got my house paid off and then i
just kept doing 15 of my income into
retirement in mutual funds that's not
that much really
and then i every other dollar i could
scrape together for investing i just
piled it up until i paid cash for my
first little rental and that
as soon as you do that that you all that
rental income will help you buy the next
one too so it snowballs in a good
direction after you get it going
well i guess that's where i'm at now is
we do have the cash available to buy a
rental income great do it and have it
paid for
when you get that money you do that so
then you get that money where do you put
the money from the rent you just put it
in some account to go towards another
rental yeah that's what i've done
uh and i use some of my other money to
go towards the next rental because i
love real estate and it sounds like you
do too but you don't have to do that
it's not like mandatory part of the
ramsey plan or something some people
don't like real estate in dealing with
renters and all and they just do mutual
funds that's okay but what i have done
was i would took i would take extra cash
and i just opened up
a simple s p 500 no commission
uh low turnover mutual fund just an
index fund okay and i just dump money in
that index fund until there's enough in
there to buy another piece of real
estate and then i dump money in there
until there's enough money to buy
another piece of real estate the
interesting thing was it got to the
point that
uh
it turned out to be a lot of money
because as you get a few properties that
account builds really fast you know what
i'm saying
so just just keep going it just seems
like a better a better a safer bet with
the real estate versus
putting it in in the funds it is safer
in some ways in that you control more of
the variables and real estate is less
volatile
it doesn't jump up and down as much in
price as the stock market does uh it's
also a whole heck of a lot more hassle
you know stuff breaks on real estate
they never call me from my mutual fund
company and want an air conditioner
yeah
and the me and the mutual fund company
never calls and says you know i lost my
job i'm not paying my rent we don't ever
get that from them
so uh it makes a little less and it's a
little more volatile but it's also a
whole lot less hassle i just kind of
open up my email and see how much money
i made it's not much to it on the mutual
funds but i like the real estate but i
grew up in that business i love real
estate and i've got a bunch of it so but
you're doing it exactly in the right
order that's incredible paid for house
has the cash to buy a rental property
i'd i'd go and pull the trigger on this
one
yeah and and
you know usually when we get that call
it's somebody who's uh
still fighting through their credit card
debt or their me or their student loan
and they're wanting dollar signs i've
been watching some weekend get rich
quick thing on real estate crap and
they're about to get their self into a
mess yeah i see that a lot on tick tock
that's the hot thing is flip houses and
real estate investing and these are the
same people who have a hundred thousand
dollars in student loan debt who are
about to walk into a nightmare yeah
i mean tick tock
pretty good for dance moves maybe but
not great for financial advice yeah i'm
just thinking financial advice and tick
tock this is like
there's a lot of bad financial advice on
tick tock i will say that yeah that's
like the uh youngster's
version of stupid you know the other one
that gets me is on the other and the old
people version is
if your financial products are
advertised between snuggies and walk-in
bathtubs uh they're probably not good
you know if washed up uh
hollywood figures are if tom selleck is
selling you whole life insurance yeah
that would be um yeah it would be
long-term or not long-term care what is
it that yeah
no they're selling uh reverse mortgages
oh that's a horrible shout out yeah you
need to do a fine print on reverse
mortgage that would be a fun one that
would be good i'm here we can play some
of those tv timeshare in there you could
do timeshare on one you could do because
if you guys wanna the next step the next
season for fine print you guys need to
email and let george know what he's
supposed to talk about we've had lots of
great ideas come through it's the email
the fine print at ramseysolutions.com if
you've got an idea for uh an episode
around a company that is scamming people
a product that's terrible for people and
there is no shortage dave yeah
apparently there's not the time share
industries won the reverse mortgages are
another one that you could do um and i
thought of one this morning when i was
listening to the fine print and um on my
walk and
uh is uh actual scams we had a lady
calling a guy calling his mom had gotten
scammed
and uh not not just uh
you know semi-legal scams like we're
talking about right here like time
shares are legalized fraud right
like getting your personal information
i'm talking about like you know the
spanish set up or the nigerian prince or
there's you know there's some basic
setups with these scams and if you learn
kind of how they work and expose them
and uh maybe interview somebody with the
fbi or something on on these scams that
would be good i mean we've had some
we've had some really interesting calls
over there i have fallen for one i fell
for one of it yes i was really
embarrassed to say it i shipped some
shoes to nigeria off of craigslist i was
selling some shoes on craigslist the guy
said hey send them to my cousin i'll pay
you extra for the shipping and i got the
email and i said wow he's really willing
to pay the extra 50 bucks to ship him
and so i just went ahead and shipped him
and it turns out the email was not from
paypal no once i shipped it i never
checked my actual bank account to see if
the money was really there i just saw an
email from paypal and i went all right
he's good to go and i shipped him so
that was my uh it was an ebay scam that
went around similar to that for a while
yeah that they would actually cut and
paste and put the paypal on it and uh
you know get you to go ahead and pay the
wrong account and it was somehow they
were hacking into the system and it was
a real embarrassment you can replicate
emails and websites to look just like
the actual company irs is one they
probably stop things we need your
information they're fishing scams we
need your information in order to get
fishing with a pap by the way oh yeah
yeah but the yeah you need to do an
episode i know it's good i have a lot of
stupid tacks with it with scams that's
very and senior citizens are the most
society
needed tennis shoes and you weren't
suspicious i just thought wow what a
nice guy he wants to send these to his
cousin in nigeria and i was you know i
was probably who happens to be a prince
yes there was no prince involved there
was no red flag
no royalty here no red flags except i'm
shipping
tennis shoes to nigeria other than that
and guys looking on craigslist for these
yeah this is where we pick them up
that's generally where we buy our shoes
for not here
well i just did a segment uh on for
media today helping senior citizens
figure out cell phone plans and there
was one about they wanted to know how to
avoid scams exactly and so because
that's
the primary target of the scams is
senior citizens wire us money buy us
gift cards give us some personal
information so i always say when in
doubt hang up if it seems suspicious it
seems too good to be true yeah yeah and
that pretty much ends the whole thing
when you do that so very very good
answer good answer george campbell
ramsey personality my co-host on this
thanksgiving eve
where we are thankful for james childs
and kelly very thankful for them austin
in the booth thankful he's training
and that kelly has let him live so far
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host thank
you for joining us open phones at aaa
825-5225
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five it is thanksgiving eve and
so your ticket onto the show today will
be to tell us what you are
thankful for as you come on the air we
want to know what you're thankful for
because well that's what we're about
around here thanksgiving
gratitude
generosity
these are the character traits of people
who have high
quality lives
george we have a wonderful documentary
out called that you guys all need to
watch over the thanksgiving holiday if
you haven't seen it called borrow future
and it's already been highly successful
you can watch it on google play on apple
tv
and on amazon prime as well and you can
watch it at borrowed future.com if you
want to do that we don't care however
you want to do it but pull it up online
and watch it with your family while
you're hanging out
maybe kind of
maybe your eyes are rolling back in your
head just a little bit from too much
turkey and this will wake you up because
it'll scare the p wadden out of you the
student loan
thing is a real deal and george you
hosted the original podcast series
called borrow future that led us into
doing the full length documentary and so
when you and i see something like ohio
state president announces debt-free
degree initiative it gets our attention
yeah it's it's incredible i was reading
through this and what they're doing is
they're going to offer undergraduate
students the chance to graduate
debt-free after four years with this new
initiative and that's going to include a
combination of scholarships grants and
paid internships and i love the
president christina johnson her heart
behind this
is not to
do free tuition and free college but
instead to offer this
in exchange for financial literacy uh
financial literacy instruction and
students committing to graduate within
four years they're doing a lot of
endowment and fundraising of course to
help offset the cost of this and what's
really neat is it covers everything
tuition room board fees books the whole
shebang so that's a pretty incredible
initiative yeah this is brilliant
because it's the way people ought to be
going to college on their own
but the president of ohio state has
christina johnson has
just done a great job spearheading this
and all she's saying is
we're going to help you get the
scholarships we're going to put you into
an intern program where you work
particularly in the summer between
duh
uh you know and then you go back with
that money and we're going to get some
private funding some private donors to
be able to help cover the difference uh
she said it begins with a small pilot
next year and will cover tuition room
board estimated cost of about 100
million a year once it's fully
implemented at the end of 10 years and
the university plans to an 800 million
dollar fundraising campaign to create an
endowment to where it just feeds that in
perpetuation
and it's brilliant it's a way to do it
and
there's no reason
if you're going to an in-state school
that you should have student loans you
should be able to get enough
scholarships to work enough and manage
your time and get out in four years
not six years i love that commitment as
part of this initiative you know you
don't you're not getting free college
and it's not and it's not a uh
it's not a socialized thing she was very
clear to say that in the press release
uh it is not free tuition it is not free
college it's not any of that it's a
program that allows you to go to school
work get scholarships
get done in four years and be done
debt-free i love this way to go we
salute you yeah they're rolling it out
next fall with 125 low and middle income
students and uh you got to fill out
financial forms every year kind of
similar to a fafsa situation but i think
it's so great that students can do this
knowing they're going to leave with zero
debt as long as they commit to four
years paid internship really simple
things that anyone can do well and this
is again it's they're committing to
doing stuff they should be doing
so it's not like it's harsh
it's not some kind of bizarre
thing they're not training their souls
you don't have to train tigers i mean
that's not what it is you're not you
don't have to run backwards for you know
in front of a speeding car you don't
have to do anything you work yep
you apply for scholarships
you do internship and you finish in four
years
what a concept
wow
i mean
this is neat
i hope this works i hope this is a model
that other schools can take and go we're
going to do the same thing ohio state
did and all of a sudden we're going to
see so many more students walking off
that stage completely debt free well and
what's interesting is the associated
press which generally comes out you know
pretty much to the left of karl marx on
stuff
has given her a positive push on this
they put they took the press release
from ohio state and ran the good parts
so
somehow they convinced the ap that this
is a good idea which is freaking amazing
because generally the ap is
well i think the one thing that unifies
us all regardless of your politics is
the fact that this is a mess and it's a
nightmare and i love what borrowed
future did to to really paint the
picture of where this is at and offer a
solution
yeah i agree with that
i mean
regardless of politics we all think
there's a problem but the difference is
we think there's different solutions yes
and she came out on the free market side
not the uh you should you know college
pay for that college
tuition is a is a human right bullcrap
you know
uh so instead it's your right to go pay
for it
uh and here's how you can do it and we
have a program i love it i think it's
fabulously done it's a great initiative
it's well laid out they put enough uh
information out in the press release to
make it where the whole system is
believable uh it's a 10-year
rollout it's going to take them some
time to do the thing they're doing it
right it's not announced it's not uh
flashing the pan it's not microwave
they're uh but i you know i i think you
could get your
alumni behind something like this
i mean there's a
sharon ramsey scholarship at the
university of tennessee now that's cool
that's over there that the ramsey family
foundation funds every year but
i can tell you this that this is the
kind of stuff alumni that have done well
in the business world would come back
and support
kids going to school free or going to
school if they're working and you know i
would support some scholarships for
stuff like this this is the kind of
thing i think you could draw a lot of
money in yeah so her needing to raise
800 million dollars to
uh
create the endowment for this is very
doable yeah i think even outside people
would say i'd love to throw some money
in the pot and be generous in this way
to allow someone to go to school
debt-free that otherwise maybe couldn't
i would rather do that than be taxed
even more and be forced to so that the
government with this inefficiencies
actually decided that it was grandpa and
was going to give everybody free tuition
which is a bunch of crap yeah
i mean this is socialism
and so um this kind of stuff is a good
free market answer to generosity
to get people
through school so we salute you uh the
president of ohio state
university pristine our president
christina johnson well done well done
some of you other universities
especially your state schools could
follow suit it might be the smartest
best things you've ever done because
higher ed kind of has a black eye right
now
oh by the way be sure and you watch
borrowed future this weekend with your
family you don't want to miss this
uh several hundred thousand have already
watched it and it's uh already stirring
up a holy ruckus which was our full
intent so be sure and watch that
documentary uh and make sure some of the
people in your family that think that
this student loan thing is okay or
whatever make sure they get to see it
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality host
of the fine print also host of the
entree leadership podcast is my co-host
today as we talk about your life and
your money open phones at triple eight
eight two five five
two two five you jump in we'll talk
darlene is in san antonio texas hi
darlene welcome to the ramsey show hey
thank you dave thank you for taking my
call i've been trying to get through
since last friday so i'm really excited
to speak with you
my question is
i put a contract offer in on a
small fixer upper
and it was a cash offer and they were
asking 90 high 90s
and i came in
just slightly below that so they did
accept the offer
and
basically
basically i was going to buy the house
with the loan i did not get the loan so
i had to terminate the contract within
the three-day termination period
and the seller and the seller's agent
did not like that so they said well
we're still going to hold you to the
contract and the earnest money and my
buyer's agent said she's perfectly
within her three-day
termination period
and um
i did speak with the title company and
the title company the lady who uh
pretty much manages the title company
she's the main person there told me that
you're in your three-day termination
period you did not present the earnest
check and also the contract is full of
holes and there's uh the contract is
incomplete there's two pages missing and
i'm not going to accept the contract
and she asked us what us being my
buyer's agent myself what is your
concern and the buyer's agent said well
they're going to try to hold her liable
for the earnest money and possible
breach of contract
and she said well i don't see how that's
going to happen when i the contract is
dissolved so i just kind of wanted your
thoughts on that
where's the earnest money now
it was never presented because i didn't
get my loan to oh so they will sue you
for the earnest money and for specific
performance
on the contract
okay
um well i'm not an attorney but it
sounds like the title company has looked
at it who looks at contracts every day
and has said this is not an enforceable
situation so
you can sue someone for anything you can
just make up a lie
and sue someone
that's happened to me recently
so it can you can just make up crap okay
and just sue somebody and just right
completely bogus thing that didn't even
occur
and so in your mind this this is a
contract it's bogus it didn't occur but
they could go sue you on it uh the
question is would they win
um and do they really want to write all
the legal checks they got to write to
sell a stinking 90 000 house because
even a state court action is going to
cost them 15 to 25 thousand dollars
right and the house needed a roof it had
it was just a shell and i thought well
maybe i can afford it a little at a time
and it didn't there was no way i could
come up with the money so i was declined
and i said i'm sorry but my agent failed
to put that and um
the contract was contingent upon
financing
yes
well that's dumber than a rock it was uh
it was she my buyer's agent failed to
include a clause saying that
depending on the loan if the loan is i
should be contingent upon financing and
she didn't and
i mean you shouldn't have signed it you
should have been able to read where's
the contingency on financing yeah well
did you sign it blind yeah the offer was
she said as soon as the offer is
accepted that go it is the contract it
becomes the contract i know so why did
you make an offer that was not
contingent upon financing you and your
buyer's agent ought to have your butts
kicked it well i explained that she
didn't she didn't get that part so i
told her my loan did it was declined so
you know there's no way i can
no you misunderstand the offer that you
made did not contain
the offer that you made and was accepted
did not contain a contingency on
financing meaning the contract was not
contingent on financing you nor your
buyer's agent made sure it was in there
that was dumb
and that's what i was asking for my
buyer's agent no no i'm asking you
you're the grown-up person to sign the
contract
your buyer's agent was done but so were
you
i mean you said you stepped up into this
trap now i don't know what's the
three-day thing is texas got a three-day
ride of rescission on residential real
estate companies
that's that was their right up in the
offer oh they had they gave you three
days they gave me three days that was
the first thing on the offer
so
that's the termination period that you
get three days on a cash offer and that
was the seller's write-up so that's
weird too okay and they did not complete
they didn't complete the contract they
left out two pages and if the contract
is not completed then it isn't listen in
every state in the united states a real
estate contract has to be signed by both
parties to be fully executed and become
a contract otherwise it's an offer and a
counter offer and it sounds like that
you dealt with the most incompetent
group of people i've heard of in a long
time in the real estate business
none of this is rocket science
and so
yeah i hope you learned your lesson
don't make stuff that count on three day
rights of rescission put in there what
this is going on if the deal is
contingent upon financing put it in
there
make it part of the deal it sounds like
they're trying to take advantage of this
this hole they did take advantage of it
and they took advantage of the fact that
there's not a three-day that there that
the contract wasn't completed properly
so there isn't actually even a contract
you said there's two pages missing
it wouldn't be enforceable anyway and
there's no earnest money actually
transferred hands to start with so you
know the whole deal was just really
something they're trying to spook her
into getting some some easy money from
this wow they're just mad because she
didn't close that's all it is and and
they all ought to be mad at it
themselves for doing this deal everyone
should all four parties should have
their butts kicked in this deal it's
just horribly executed and that's why
there's so much disappointment but i
don't think you're going to get sued and
i don't think they're going to win if
you do see you now i'm not a lawyer
you'd have to talk to a lawyer to be
sure
but
i think your title company person is
maybe the only one that's competent in
the whole discussion here
so
real estate can get messy if you don't
do it right guys if listen
not referring to her situation
uh but just in general
i was talking to a real estate agent the
other day when i got my real estate
license in 1978
people used to like consider writing a
contract like
giving their word
like you're going to keep your word like
it's like when i sign a contract that
says i'm going to do something that
means i gave my word and i'm going to do
it even if i don't like it even if it
hurts my feelings even
whatever i said i was going to do i need
to do that's integrity that's gone
apparently people just walk away from
real estate contracts like they just you
know decided
you know i'm gonna go buy 73 pairs of
clothes try them all on and take them
back the next day i mean it's that kind
of crap that's the way they treat house
deals now and you know you're executing
a real estate contract on a house
including our caller but but everybody
else out there more importantly than her
make sure that what you're doing is
something you are able and willing to
follow through on
don't mess with people's lives
you know don't play games
and so uh i sold my personal residence
this year
very expensive property
and
i took a
ernest might check
for this reason right here
because
i was going to be if they didn't want to
close and want to walk away i was going
to be happy
and put that much money in my pocket and
that earnest my check was camped at my
title company you know and so there's
you know there's just you just cannot
you've got to
uh
don't enter into these things
willy-nilly don't enter into these
things on impulse
this is a real estate transaction it's
massive
you know make sure that before you shake
hands and you sign on the dotted line
that you're able and you're willing to
do what that offer says now if the offer
says contingent upon financing you're
unable to get the financing then you're
out of the deal
and that's what should have been done in
this last caller
uh and instead of a you know sneaking
around in us out inside of a three-day
receipt write a recession if the offer
says contingent upon accepting the
report from the
home inspector
then when the report comes in
if there's three three dollar things
morally you should close on the house
you know
now you have the right technically to
walk away i don't like the inspection
report yes three three dollar things
which means you were just playing
freaking games to start with and you're
screwing around with somebody's home
now you shouldn't do that people do it
all the time nowadays so yeah be careful
out there lack of commitment
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you've ever gone through
a life emergency you weren't prepared
for financially well we've all just
about been there you know what secure
stomach sweaty palms feeling
is all about as a parent you hope your
child never has to go through an
experience like that but teaching
teenagers how to be smart with money
before they make dumb mistakes well that
can be a big job too and this is how it
gets you ready for life you don't have
to resort to the school of hard knocks
to teach your kids with our digital
self-study courses your teen can learn
the right way to handle money no matter
what curve balls they get thrown at them
as life as they go down life's roads
right if your teen has a tablet computer
they're set to start learning how to
budget no instructor is needed they can
learn how to save and invest how to be
outrageously generous how to write a
resume how to start their own business
parents get your kids off to a great
financial start and go to
ramseysolutions.com
self study to learn more about all of
the different courses that we have
available for your middle or high
schooler our question today comes from
blinds.com
great american company they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee if you screw up
if you mismeasure you pick the wrong
color i've done both
they'll remake your window blinds for
free
that's a pretty big guarantee like a
your stupid guarantee i'm stupid
guarantee that's pretty cool you have
free samples free shipping and new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more use the promo code ramsay to
get the best deal at blinds.com today's
question comes from sebastian in south
carolina i went gazelle intense the day
i graduated college and paid off 38 000
in 17 months i'm an engineer making
seventy thousand i lived on rice and
beans and beans and rice while using
around forty five percent of my income
to pay off my student loans which were
my only debts i'm now struggling to make
it through baby step three i have two
months of expenses saved up already but
it's taken me three times longer than i
had expected should i feel bad about how
slow my progress is now that i'm
debt-free how do i find more motivation
to save faster i feel like i worked so
hard to get out of debt but i don't have
the same intensity on baby step 3 as i
did back in baby step 2.
this is pretty common this is a tough
one because people get discouraged
there's not the immediate reward when
you see the debt pay off and you might
be tired you're in the middle of the
marathon after baby step two and i
understand i have empathy for those who
go man baby step three isn't as exciting
as as the excitement of debt snowball
paying off those debts getting rid of
the lenders and all of that so i
understand that but here's my question
where did that 45 percent of the income
go that was going towards the debt
you should have been through this by now
but it sounds like there's some other
things we're getting a little
lackadaisical with
not only the motivation go down but the
spending went up yes and uh the amount
of money going towards this baby step
three is not very good and that's what
he's saying how do i get back to that
and so what i would do is i think you
need to lay it out there and go okay i
can either let this pain go on for nine
months or i can let it go on for three
months
and the deeper i sacrifice the shorter
i'm in the pain because once you finish
baby step three you're no longer in
gazelle intensity now you're on
intentionality and now you can loosen up
and very carefully very intentionally
spending money but very carefully very
intentionally
uh
you know
moving on through the other baby steps
as well but the intensity needs to stay
up through this and i think if you just
do sit down
you know
you are an engineer so you can do the
math right and go okay
if i go back to my old ways
for three months i can be done
but if i don't it's gonna take me nine
months now what do you want to do you
want to kind of just slosh around for
nine months or go hardcore for three and
then be done
yeah i i that would give me help if i
could see the light come closer
as you know the light then the tunnel
comes closer as a result of increasing
my intensity yeah if i'm at the doctor
getting a shot i want it to be quick and
painful versus not so quick and a dull
pain forever and so that's what i think
we're feeling here with sebastian's
situation he needs to just remind
himself why he's doing this he wants to
get to where he's building for the
future instead of paying for the pass
and this is that final force field
between him and life where he doesn't
have to worry anymore and he has that
financial peace so i think you need to
remind yourself of the why and get that
motivation back and realize that you
could be done in a month or two months
or you could let this sit for another 12
and be frustrated that's that's exactly
it that's the only shot i've got at it
if i'm in his shoes because i don't i
mean no one thinks oh let's sacrifice
and go deep that's how that's so fun
no one thinks that unless you're kind of
weird but i mean most of us are going
we're doing this we're going to live
like no one else so that
we can live and give like he's so close
i mean you did the beans and rice thing
dude and here's the point it's easy to
talk to yourself and say that worked
it worked
so let's do it again
logan is with us in atlanta hi logan
welcome to the ramsay show
hi
what are you thankful for today
so i'm thankful actually for family and
then
i'm thankful for the owner of the
company i work for because she told my
brother-in-law which is my manager about
you guys
oh wow and he told me about you guys so
chain reaction
cool how can we help
um so i was actually offered a new
position at work
the downfall i make
about 19 an hour i'm supposed to be
getting raised doll raise
annual raise with my uh evaluation
the end of this month
and
the um the new position i won't
raise anything i won't gain any money
for a whole year and i lose out on about
500 a month
but then after the first year
i'll make an extra
ten dollars
an hour i'm just not really sure what to
do okay are you going to be paid hourly
at both of these
yes
why are they cutting why are they
cutting your pay then to give you a
promotion
well it's not really cutting my page i
make hourly but then i get commission
so
depending on what i sell and how much i
sell then i get 10
of that okay so you make 19 an hour plus
commission now due for a dollar an hour
raise what's the new position pay
the new position's gonna be what i make
now but i'll be learning so i won't make
any commission 19
yeah
how big a company is this
uh
it's not small but it's not big it's
probably about uh how many employees
how many about 50. okay
um
so your boss that's making you this
offer is talking to the owner
it's uh one of the managers is making an
offer yeah but not without clearing it
with the owner in a 60-person company
right yeah so the two of them are
talking it through so here's what i
would do i would just sit down with them
and go
this i really want to do this
uh but i'm taking a pay cut to do it did
you all realize that
and is there some way we can structure
this so i don't get a pay cut with my
promotion because
honestly i while i really appreciate the
promotion
and all i i that doesn't i don't know
how that works in my head and just
question it
they may come back and go you know
that's probably right i wouldn't want to
get a promotion and a pay cut
and so you know we're going to give you
you know 21 or whatever so that it
basically washes out with your old
commissions and moves you into the new
role because they're trying to move you
up
right
now when you finish when you finish your
training you said they're going to be
training you will you be making more
than
yes so um the training's gonna take
about um a year just because how much
how much is into it um because it's uh
fire protection stuff
um
so once i get fully trained in that
department i'll make uh about thirty
dollars an hour
that's a big jump
yeah
okay
well maybe they do realize it you know
and just go well i really thank you for
that i still would ask the question
but i wouldn't ask it with any
entitlement or any arrogance i would
just say
hey i really want to do this is there
anything i can do
extra in the new role that would allow
you to pay me what i'm already making
total
right so that it makes this a no-brainer
right just yeah baby step one right now
so i just started out with your guys
stuff and i i just wasn't sure what to
do so i figured reach out to you guys
here's the thing don't go in and slap
your fist on the table that's not my
point we're not going we're not going in
with anything like that this is just
going
hey guys help me with this i'm a young
guy i'm trying to figure this out i
really want to do this is there anything
i can do in the new position that would
make it where you would want to pay me
the total of what i'm making right now
so that it makes it a no-brainer for me
to take this promotion because i really
want to do it yeah and just see if you
can talk them up that way the upside is
making 20k more so if it's a if he's
going to stay stable i don't want him
take a pay cut but even if he does he's
gonna make 20k a year from now more than
he is i like those odds if it's
guaranteed i'm taking it either way but
i'm gonna ask the question in a small
company you've got some
there's not as much policies not as much
corporate bullcrap to wade through to
get something like this considered
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
happy thanksgiving america it's
thanksgiving eve here on the ramsey show
what are you thankful for george
campbell ramsay personality is my
co-host brian is with us brian's in
cincinnati hey brian what are you
thankful for
i am thankful for the wonderful extended
family god has granted me because if it
was possible i would trade in 90 of my
blood family
that's a good answer
i love it how can we help
yes my wife and i are working on our
wills and of course we are leading each
other everything if something happens to
this one of us but we're wanting to set
up college funds for our grandchildren
as something happens to both of us
and at this point the majority of the
money would be coming from
my life insurance and the 401k
okay
and
and i have no idea where to start on
that i wasn't sure if it's
a trust fund that we would set up for
that or how we would do it and what the
401k would be the second beneficiary and
the same with the life insurance
yeah i think that you would just name
your secondary beneficiary on both uh to
be
a
a family trust a grandchild trust you
can give it a name that is formed in the
will upon your death
it's much like it's much like if you had
minor children you would leave
everything in the case of both death
both parents death into a trust to take
care of minor children until they're
grown and
you would name that trust but that trust
is formed only upon your death it's not
formed ahead of time and so then these
both of these uh accounts the life
insurance 401 k would pay into that and
then you put the terms on the trust how
you want the trust managed
and um upon your death that this would
be formed and uh who the trustee is
who's going to be managing the money and
so like in our case when we had minor
children we said okay we wanted invested
in four types of growth stock mutual
funds growth growth and income
aggressive growth and international we
want them all to have 10-year track
records
and we don't want the money sitting in a
cd and a bank because it won't even keep
up with inflation and the kids can have
money use out of it under these
circumstances and at this age whatever
balance is left in the account will be
handed over to them and so on and so you
could do the same thing here that you
say okay if they go to a
four-year school
uh that is an in-state tuition or
whatever whatever
constraints you want to put on it
um
uh and you know they need to graduate
before they're
35 i don't know 25 whatever you know
we're not going to keep we don't want
lifelong students because of this we
want them to get out and get a job and
get move on with their life that's the
purpose of it and so kind of think
through some of that and you know you
need to put some parameters on that
trust and build out the guidelines of
how it is to be operated by that trustee
then and none of this will happen until
both of you pass away
okay and uh like our oldest
granddaughter she's 10 right now she of
course at 10 it's going to change
probably but she has dreams of being a
vet
which is a lot more than a four-year
degree
uh of course she would be the first one
to hit it what would you recommend uh as
far as stating it like a cut-off point
for that to make sure there's enough for
the other and right now we have two and
a half more the next one's due in four
months yeah there would be three after
her
i mean you can just run the math out on
it and see um
it would not be unusual in something
like you're doing to make it for the
four-year degree only and if they do
post-graduate work they're on their own
okay
yeah right now it would be
like 650 000 if something happens to me
tomorrow yeah
and there's how many kids
there's would be four total at this
point yeah okay
and they're babies that's probably
enough for four-year degrees is all
in-state tuition okay by the time they
get there now it'll grow some during
that time assuming it's invested uh
because you said four there's some are
not even born so that's
you know that's part of the equation but
um you got eight years before the first
one starts tapping it so it'll double
once more i don't know yeah you may have
enough to do more than that but i think
you could have you could set up a
formula a math formula in the thing this
is you know
when the when the account is starts to
be when the first student appears
um we're going to apply this formula to
the current balance and that tells you
if you can do more than a four-year
degree would it make sense to open a 529
in their name in this case i mean i know
he wants upon death but it's something
that you could open now and let that
grow
while they're alive
it's obviously not part of the will you
could but yeah it's not part of the
wheel you'd have to do it with other
income because you can't use your 401k
money for that and you can't use life
insurance because you're not dead
so but it would have to be other money
that you came up with and funded it um
yeah i guess i'm wondering is it you
know why do they want it upon death
versus while they're still alive start
to set that up for them
well the two sources are not accessible
today
will be the only reason but if they've
got other money that is other sources of
money that's accessible then you could
look at doing that
so very cool very cool
leah is with us or lee in new york city
is it leah or lee it's leah hi great hi
happy thanksgiving what are you thankful
for
i'm thankful that my family is healthy
and that we are on baby step three yay
how can we help
hi so we have been on a budget for a
while but from time to time we keep
running into this issue of
that we can't wait for the next paycheck
to come it's almost like we're running
out of money and i feel like we're not
doing something right in dividing up the
money or the budget within the month
and also even though we are on baby step
3 and we paid off all our debt
we kind of still feel like at this point
that we're almost like living paycheck
to paycheck so to speak what's your
household income
so
um
my husband is
working um
he's making 94 9 400 take home pay
that's your household income
yes okay
so when you guys were doing a budget
when you were paying off debt was there
margin left over
um
well at the time i was also working it
was remark it was very hard it was it
was it was
so there was a drop in income not much
is that what's causing this to drop an
income from you not working
um i don't think so i mean we did have
another child and i my income wasn't so
great it was i was working only
part-time so and he also received the
raise um in the past few months okay
when you both when you do a budget both
of you sit down and look at what is
allocated to each category and you're
both agreeing to that
correct correct
and then what happens that blows it up
um
the budget is is fine we have money for
every everything and every category it's
just that as we start spending the money
and starting to track the money it's
almost like we run out of the actual
money in the bank before
um well no but the bank money is
reflected on the budget so you're you're
running out of money in the category if
you're overspending you're either
overspending a category or underfunding
a category
you if you have ninety-four hundred
taking that it's just that let's say our
bills are due
earlier than the next paycheck would
come in it's like why would you budget
that you need to budget what's the
reality is your budget's not a mythology
template that just is the way you wish
life is your budget needs to reflect
what life is
and it does no it doesn't
because your bills are coming up in a
budget outside the budget
they're coming to you and they're not in
their budget actual money is not in our
checking account you're saying it's a
timing problem but you need to be
budgeting for whatever that paycheck
coming in you need to make sure that
you've got a plan for that money and
that money needs to be able to cover
your bills
so within the month it's budgeted for
correctly it's just that the money is
not in my checking account yet
and that's what we're saying is don't
budget for money that doesn't exist
if you've got 9400 because we get paid
twice a month
okay so you've got to learn to adjust
the budget into two halves then
the two times a month where you've got a
certain amount coming out
for food
in the first month first half of the
month but you've got a bunch of other
bills hitting so your food budget may be
a little lower in the first half and a
little higher in the back half when you
don't have as many other bills hitting
so you may have to run two half budgets
that are zeroed out to make this work to
get your timing right until you can get
a little bit ahead of
the budget and and have a little bit of
slush in there to be able to make this
run
um
but
i think you guys are watching too much
netflix and not spending enough time on
this budget this is not rocket science
you can sit down and figure this out
when both of you lean into it and sit
down and look at it and push on it and
go
every one of these dollars needs a name
and it needs to it needs to reflect the
reality of our month the cable bill is
due on the 25th that has to show up in
this budget the electric bill is due on
the third that has to show up in this
budget we have to see how that's going
to work and just spend a little bit of
time on it planning it out i think you
can do it
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show did you know over 18
million people listen to the ramsay show
every week and a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country
to find a station near you head to
thermsyshow.com
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
fact that you're a baby steps
millionaire has taken the place of the
status symbol of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice the paid off home
mortgage could be an indicator that
you're a baby steps millionaire that
you're an everyday millionaire that
you're a millionaire we're going to talk
about all three this hour george camel
ramsey personality is my co-host if you
are an actual millionaire regardless of
how you got there
whether you're a baby steps millionaire
meaning you followed the baby steps to
get there
you're an everyday millionaire meaning
you started with nothing and you got
there which is a type of baby steps
millionaire um and or maybe you just hit
the lotto last week or your grandmother
left you 10 million dollars i don't find
one i'd be neat i don't care how you got
there
call us up and tell you tell us how you
became a millionaire now we need to
define this for you because some people
don't understand what a millionaire
really is an actual millionaire there's
only one definition
well that's your definite no there's
only one it's not just mine it's a
financial planning accounting
mathematics arithmetic thing
you don't get to reinvent crap because
you had a feeling once
okay
so someone that makes a million dollars
a year could be a millionaire but that
does not make them a million dollar a
millionaire a millionaire is a net worth
statement
it means that you have a million dollar
or greater
net worth your net worth is what you own
minus what you owe
assets minus liabilities on the balance
sheet is a net worth statement
until you have a million dollars in that
bottom right hand corner after you do
that calculation or more you are not a
millionaire
you're not a billionaire unless you have
a billion in that corner
you could make a billion dollars the
company that you own might have a
billion dollar top line but it doesn't
make you a millionaire doesn't make you
a billionaire it's very important to
know definitions thank you for clearing
that up dave there's
a lot of mythology out there around this
and you know i've been doing the man on
the street segments and you go and you
ask people hey what do you think when
you think millionaire they think
celebrities they think athletes they
think ceos of huge companies and the
truth is they're probably thinking
closer to billionaires and you talk
about this in your new book baby steps
millionaires defining the difference
because in people's minds they just kind
of get a little squirrely and they don't
think straight about really what it
takes and it's all about what you own
minus what you owe it's that simple yeah
well money's not that important
okay but that's this is not a moral
construct it's an arithmetic thing well
million dollars isn't enough probably
but it doesn't matter you're still a
millionaire a millionaire is a
millionaire as a millionaire it's not a
moral construct it doesn't it's not
about what i don't feel rich i don't
care
that doesn't mean you're not a
millionaire
you're feeling it's not a measure of
your feelings
if we got into that good lord in this
culture all we would do is be we'd have
to have a feeling amateur i just feel
like a millionaire dave i feel like a
million bucks today there you go there
you go
oh
well it's fun to celebrate it's a big
milestone for a lot of people well it is
a good milestone because it's not super
rich but it's richer than most people it
feels unattainable to the average person
there's about 13 million millionaires in
america today wow 13 million there's a
lot of them
and there's less than about less than a
thousand billionaires
so it's very rare to be a billionaire
it's not that rare to be a millionaire
and you can't spot them in the grocery
store hardly yeah you can't tell them
because they don't look any different
because they're not they're not they
don't have enough money to buy a private
jet they have enough money to buy a
lamborghini it's not that much it means
lamborghini's 250 000 bucks man
private jets millions of dollars they
got one million dollars you know so you
need to understand this is what we're
dealing with anyway it's still a great
milestone it's still something to be
celebrated you're still very unusual you
still have built a level of wealth and
most people never get to think about it
and it's still a great great target and
we want to celebrate you if you are a
millionaire this hour
call in and tell us how you did it we
want to interview you we're going to
call the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five jeff is
in chicago jeff what's your net worth
my net worth is three million and dave
if i may say quickly from the outset
that i came across your videos just a
couple years ago on youtube and i saw
real fast that you were given great
advice but two things that you that you
said that i really liked was that if you
don't retire a millionaire it's your
fault and if you're buying things that
you cannot afford that's not a signal
that you're wealthy that's a signal that
you're stupid those two things really
stood out for me
yeah it sounds like something i would
say
when you repeat it back to me it sounds
harsher than when i say it in my head
but yeah you said it pretty harshly but
i liked it it was a little more
entertaining when you said it i like it
all right so what's the mix of this
three million give me some category
breakdowns of where this wealth is
okay so three million my house is paid
off about 350 in value
and the 2.65 million is spread out
between my 457b
my roth and i have a taxable account in
vanguard now i also i just retired after
29 years and four months so i also have
a pension of 104 000 i don't know how
you factor that into your analysis oh
pension is the
income correct so it's you know just the
income stream so i don't know if it's
irrelevant but i just figured i'd let
you know we'll cash the check that's for
sure how old are you i wish i could 51.
51 years old how much of this 3 million
did you inherit
zero zero and your range of income
household income during your working
life what was your best household income
your worst household income so far so
when i started at 21 i would say
probably around 35 000 and then of
course over the years i got raises and i
culminated uh this year when i retired
at about 130 so i guess the mean would
be around 90 95. okay and what have you
what did you do for a living
i was a chicago police lieutenant oh
awesome very cool
all right and are you married
no okay and your degree is in what
so um i finished my college degree when
i got on a job and then several years
later i went and got my law degree and
then after that i went and i got my llm
after that which is basically an
advanced law degree wow but i never
really practiced it i just i just did i
mostly i taught some i published some
articles like on the second amendment
i'm a big pro second amendment guy and
some estate planning stuff but i never
really used it parlayed it into a source
of revenue okay and what was your gpa
back in college
high school college i was a cc minus
student it wasn't until i
got to law school that i took it
seriously and then i got good grades
okay cool so how much of this three
million dollars of uh in of net worth
that you have is there because you
borrowed money to create wealth
zero i have had a credit card since i
was 18 and i've never paid a nickel
interest on it my dad always said you
know there's a difference between what
you need and what you want and and by
the way he retired as a police officer
six years old with a million dollars
following these principles so he's in
the club too but no i didn't i never
borrowed anything other than my mortgage
okay so you got a young
brand new person on the police force
that's listening
and they're listening to this guy who's
50 something years old who's a retired
police lieutenant in chicago has 3
million dollars in net worth zero debt
of any kind
tell them how to do that and can they
still do it
well
absolutely they can do it and my first
advice would be which i've told younger
guys over the years is firstly it's a
mindset forget all the fancy cars the
fancy clothes the watches it's not
important nobody cares as a matter of
fact most people who have that stuff
actually can't afford it it reminds me
of the millionaire next door that that
chapter um big had no cattle it's all
fake oh yeah but yep but as far as
implementing it then i would say
maximize your 457 your off stay out of
debt live below your means and by the
way stay away from those cash value life
insurance policies
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at
betheltech.net and get one thousand to
twenty five hundred dollars off of your
tuition again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
so
[Music]
happy thanksgiving america george
campbell ramsey personality and i are
here to talk to you about millionaires
this hour and we're talking with real
millionaires not your broke
brother-in-law with an opinion people
who have actually done it
how did they do it did they inherit
their money did they steal from someone
are all rich people evil are they all
nba stars or nfl stars or actors or uh
music
icons no no and no and no
all the data tells us that but there are
a lot of political opinions and jealousy
there's a lot of sadness uh there's a
lot of uh anger
there's a lot of socialism out there
floating around in america and uh we're
here to defeat all of that with actual
facts yeah i i love what you say about
this money makes you more of whoever you
are so are there some evil wealthy
people sure there's some evil poor
people out there too and so it really is
not a reflection of character uh but
there is a piece of this where you've
interviewed so many of these
millionaires and it turns out just work
ethic and consistency over time will
make you a millionaire that's how you do
it sure fire way
and we started seeing so many of them
that were baby steps millionaires that
actually followed the baby steps because
i've been teaching financial peace
university and the seven baby steps for
close to 30 years now and so
lots and lots of people because the
average millionaire takes about 17 years
to get there and so
lots and lots of people have followed
the baby steps and so they're literally
baby steps millionaires and so uh people
kept asking about that and and there was
all this all this pushback well you know
you only follow ramsay until you're not
broke and then you if you really want to
be wealthy you don't follow ramsay well
it turns out a lot of wealthy people
became wealthy because of exactly what
we teach at ramsey and so um i wrote a
new book i haven't done one in eight
years but i thought it was time to do
one we had a ramsey personality named
chris hogan who did a wonderful book
here called everyday millionaires we've
sold quite a few of those half million
of them or so and that book is all about
the research study that we at ramsey did
and the conclusions of that study we'll
reference it this hour as well
uh and all about the the largest study
of millionaires ever done in north
america over 10 000 of them and so chris
did that book when he was here and uh
that came out a couple of years back and
did very very well and then i'm doing a
follow-up book um that is not the same
thing but it is about the same subject
in a sense because it's about
millionaires only it's baby step
millionaires and so what i've done is
gone through and said okay if you don't
think you can do it here's why you don't
think and here's where you're wrong and
here's what the math says and here's
what happens when you follow the baby
steps exactly what you will do and how
you will get there so if you've heard
all about the baby steps you're going to
hear about them again there's nothing in
here that's new insight it's just
showing you it's proof positive that if
you follow the baby steps you will
become a millionaire and then some and i
love on the website when i went to check
out this book it said the quickest right
way to become a millionaire and i love
that because we don't do get rich quick
we do get rich slow and get rich on
purpose and get rich where you stay rich
and you don't lose it all like i did the
first time i did this so baby steps
millionaires is on sale now at
ramseysolutions.com you can pre-order
the book you'll get the
baby steps millionaires audiobook ebook
and you'll get the legacy journey audio
book and e-book you'll get the baby
steps millionaire live stream which
comes out in january with the book uh
the ramsey smart tax you'll get to file
your taxes free with that and you'll
have the ramsey plus 30 day free trial
all of these are upgrades and free
things coming to you
almost 200 worth of items when you buy a
200 book pre-ordered it comes out and
will actually be shipped on january the
11th but it's uh you can see it on
amazon you can see it on our website and
it all came out of the everyday
millionaires movement with chris hogan
the everyday millionaires movement came
out of me doing this hour
where we're talking with real
millionaires and discovering who they
really are graceland is a millionaire
graceland is in tulsa oklahoma graceland
what is your net worth
in 85 000. say it again
185 thousand okay
okay well i'm gonna call it 1.1 good for
you all right give me a little breakdown
on your 1.1 what's the categories
for retirement i have 875
000
in my house i have 60 000
and then in taxable investments and
other savings i have a hundred and fifty
thousand good for you how old are you
i'm 37. whoa a young millionaire good
for you okay how much of this did you
inherit
well that is unique to me i think and
why i wanted to call because starting in
my 30s i have been gifted 180 000
from my parents at 30 000 a year for six
years okay so 180 of the 1.1
has come to you and uh so they're
they're using the gift tax law to
transfer some out of their estate right
correct okay that's very cool i love
that and you're right this is unusual so
i love your call thank you for joining
us okay so you got 180 since you were 30
six years or 31 years old
30 000 a year 15 from mom 15 from dad to
meet gift tax guidelines and you've done
what with that money
it was always agreed upon that i would
use it to max out my uh roth ira and
401k i love your parents
i love your parents they're changing
their family tree
so well done so what is your income
so my income currently is about 61 000.
and what do you do for a living
i'm a civil engineer
okay
so you're good with numbers too then
and um and so do you fee do you resent
your mom and dad putting all these
guidelines on this
no
i i mean i know that the reason i'm here
is because i'm guided and gifted by my
wise parents um
and it's always an agreement with them
um
what you know they they
we had a wedding this year i just got
married and it was a big negotiation how
much to spend on the wedding but um i
always appreciate their generosity wow
did you ever think you'd be a
millionaire at 37 years old
no you know five years ago i was halfway
here and i felt so free
but i did not know what would happen so
fast i mean the market returns you just
you you might question whether you
should leave it in mutual funds in the
market
but
it's
i don't know i don't think it's a
question anymore
um so when'd you get married
i got married this month hey
congratulations
so how does uh how how does he fit into
all of this from a relationship
standpoint is is he bought in on this
whole program obviously or you wouldn't
have married him
we did fpu together before we got
married and he didn't come uh
from the same kind of understanding of
money nobody made fear
um and so we agreed no credit cards he
cut up his credit cards and he just got
on board he sees what i've been able to
do and is um
ready to be a partner in that what a
dreamboat
there it is
this is everything every parent wants is
you and who you married this feels like
i mean my kids are your age and so this
is like perfect thank you thank you for
proving that what your mom and dad did
can be done what is their net worth
would you guess
well it's it's
um over probably over five million yeah
i was gonna guess that yeah good
awesomeness very very cool all right so
your 180 that you've collected since in
the last six years
is
probably
close to half of your net worth is that
fair
um that it grew yeah i
don't know i'm just guessing i was
doubling it yeah so probably probably
500 000 double it or triple it and then
the rest of it you've done
that's so neat
that is so powerful
this is how the parents listening
this is how you change your family tree
you raise a graceland
and listen to what graceland did she
respected her mom and dad she respected
and understood their their their process
she embraced it she became it uh she
wouldn't marry outside of it she taught
her new husband how to do it as part of
the agreement this is how you do it this
is how you change your family tree
because you can't dump enough money on
dumb kids to straighten them out
this is this you are awesome kid i'm
loving you thank you so much for joining
us i love your story i love your mom and
dad i love your new husband i love you
you're all you're just you're the whole
package that made my day so much love
so much love this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
it's a baby steps millionaire theme hour
you may have become a millionaire using
the baby steps you may have become a
millionaire on your own without the baby
steps or you may just have become a
millionaire maybe your parents gave you
some money maybe you inherited some
money we don't care how you got your
million dollars we want to talk to you
because we want to talk to real
millionaires not people with an opinion
that are broke
because jealousy and envy are not
mathematical formulas
and then we'll talk about the real
statistics of millionaires the reason we
do this is we want to let you know that
it's possible for you to get there
that's what the book baby steps
millionaires is all about it is the i
have proven
through every possible lens that you can
analyze it
to you by the time you finish this book
that it is not only possible it's
probable
that you will become a millionaire if
you do the stuff we teach brooks is with
us in oklahoma city hi brooks how about
your net worth
hey good afternoon dave um our net worth
is 1.1 million good for you give me a
little breakdown on that by category
yes sir uh 600 in iras and the thrift
savings plan 155 in some real estate
investments 130 in a taxable brokerage
um 30 in college funds and then the rest
is some equity in the house and cash
good for you how old are you 39. all
right my wife is 40. excellent excellent
so how much of this 1.1 did you inherit
none of it zero
and what's been the range of your
household income since you guys started
working best year and worst year
so uh worst year was 20k right out of
college and then
last year we were fortunate to be at
about 140. good for you and what do you
guys do for a living
i'm an officer in the air force and my
wife has a small business she runs thank
you for your service excellent you have
a four-year degree
uh yes sir and a couple masters i'm a as
my wife said on our very first date i'm
a huge nerd ah i love it she's got a
degree as well okay what's your uh some
of your degrees in
i have a mechanical engineering
undergrad an mba and then a master of
arts and military operations perfect
what's your average gpa across all that
uh
around a 3-8 to a 4-0 somewhere in there
okay phenomenal well done sir well done
and you're millionaires starting from
nothing
as an air force officer and a small
business owner by the time you're 40
years old
and that can that's not all by ourselves
we had we had help along the way from
family as far as opportunities but
um we've been blessed very blessed
when you mean when you say opportunities
what do you mean
my dad's done real estate and once i got
out of college and
thought it was a good idea at the time
to take out some money to invest he he
put me in some gave me some
opportunities to make money that i had
not necessarily earned at my young age
at the time and
um they worked out really well but
looking back uh you know if i hadn't had
my dad there to help me so he kind of
did he kind of kickstart so you had some
of the stuff you had some guidance but
he didn't give you money
yes sir that's about right all right
that's what i was trying to figure out
excellent well well done
very well done and uh very well played
okay so you're talking to a a young
enlisted man or woman can they still do
this
absolutely what do they need to do
have a plan just
ahead of time don't look back at your
money look at what it's doing for you in
the future and you have to become
comfortable with living below your means
and
you you can't necessarily go out and buy
all the flashy stuff that your friends
are doing and and you need to be okay
with that and uh
you know there's
the math all makes sense to me a math
guy but there's an emotional component
that's tied up in finances and
um you got to kind of come to terms with
that as an individual and uh
my wife wanted to say you can't
you got to be looking ahead and you
can't focus on the near-term benefits if
you want to have some long-term paybacks
agreed now have you all had a life
during this 15 or 20 years or have you
just lived in a cave and collected lent
and coupons
no we've had we've had a fantastic life
we've had some great vacations and
good opportunities and just we've had a
lot of fun
but i drive an eight-year-old car that's
paid for and i have no desire to get
something new because i want to spend
that money on
the family and trips and experiences and
then i don't i drive 15 minutes to work
every day i don't really care what i
drive wow so your priorities shifted as
you begin to build wealth and you
decided what's important for you and
your family
yes we did um as a team we talk every
every month a couple times about the
budget about about quarterly or half a
year we'll kind of sit down and see if
we're if our priorities have changed and
if we need to shift
where our
emphasis is and and things like that
because again life happens things change
and
we're so more flexible but we have some
guidelines we're both baby steps folks
and so it's gotten us to a fantastic
place where we
can have a lot of fun and know that our
future is
pretty secure well thank you for sharing
your story and thank you again for your
service we're very proud of you 40 years
old 1.1 million dollar net worth liz is
up next and liz is in lansing michigan
liz what's your net worth
uh our net worth is four million dollars
cool give me a little break down on that
buy category yeah
okay so uh we have one son left in
college and so he has a hundred grand in
his 529
uh we have 300 000 in cash
uh
and then the rest is
investments for retirement uh a six
hundred thousand dollar paid for house
um
yeah
so i think i think that's it okay so you
got about three million in your 401ks
and iras
yeah yeah a little bit a little bit over
that i think okay very cool how old are
you
uh 54. 54. all right and how much of
this did you inherit
i i received an inheritance about six
months ago for fifty five thousand
dollars for my aunt uh you were already
millionaires
yes so you're not millionaires because
of an inheritance is that correct no
no no no okay my husband and i both put
ourselves through college
we
um
we actually started on your plan about
15 years ago
and
it it helped us just lay out
the steps that we needed to take and we
just followed them and
it's amazing absolutely amazing what
it's what it's done i'm blown away so
what is uh what's the range of your
income since you guys started working
best household income and worst
household income
best 310
uh worst
um
probably about 170.
wow what do you guys do for a living
so my husband was a stay-at-home dad for
a long time he he now works for um he's
a project manager
and i'm a sales manager
okay
for who or for what kind of an industry
yeah for medical device industry ah okay
very lucrative good for you you've been
killing it
well done so great incomes but also made
that great income go to work
yeah i mean it
really the plan that you laid out for us
we're great at following a structure and
a plan and it's
it's been so
just has given us peace so we we have
paid for all of we have three children
grown uh two kids done with college all
paid for uh our daughter it made it
possible for her to go to notre dame and
for us to pay for it all
uh it we we've gone on european
vacations every summer for
oh gosh 10 years i met my father for the
first time 11 years ago wow and he's
he's european and it made it possible
for my kids and our family to get to
know our european family and spend you
know a couple weeks every summer with
them because we had the money to do it
wow um we drive paid for cars that what
is your what's your degree in
um engineering okay and what is that
what was your gpa
uh 3.4 cool
okay
last thing in 20 or 30 seconds can it
still be done and what should somebody
do if they want to do it
yeah it can be done i mean
really on any income it's amazing
listening to the callers in your show
that's inspired me the most the people
that
uh they make forty fifty thousand
dollars a year and they pay off this
debt and they win
and
so just follow the plan buckle down for
the for the brief amount of time that
you have to be gazelle intense and then
just you know then you get to live
live like no one else so later you can
live and give like no it's not a theory
you can do this wow
it's a baby steps millionaires theme
hour all about talking to real
millionaires regardless of how they got
there we want to hear your story triple
eight 825-5225
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture today colossians 3 17 and
whatever you do in word or deed do all
in the name of the lord jesus
giving thanks to god the father through
him
william arthur ward said gratitude can
transform common days into thanksgiving
turn routine jobs into joy and change
ordinary opportunities
into blessings
it's a baby steps millionaire's theme
hour meaning we are talking to
millionaires regardless of how they
become a millionaire we want to know
what really happened
did it re where'd your wealth really
come from
there's a lot of mythology out there
that people think that you have to be
famous an entertainer a rock star an
athlete
to become a millionaire less than one
percent of millionaires are those people
statistically that's the actual data
uh millionaires have to be to become
wealthy you have to be a crook
um i've been doing this theme hour for
years and i've never talked to anyone
that became a millionaire by being a
crook
uh and so that's just jealousy and
immaturity
and envy speaking this idea that wealth
comes from thievery is ridiculous in the
culture today
who would continue to do business with a
thief
no one
um you have to be brilliant you have to
have a 4.2 gpa
i seldom talk to a millionaire that's
got a gpa that has a matter of fact most
of them are in threes pretty average now
most of them most of us are you know
mine's a 2.97 i'm still pissed about the
3 100 of a point but yeah
um so
so it's not all about intellect and it's
not all about me not career i seldom run
into somebody's got a 1.6 gpa
so i mean you have to have a certain
amount of gray matter right to get there
but
um
but this idea that that you know that
that unless you're unusually brilliant
you don't have a chance
unless you uh
you know you you strike it rich with uh
uh
you know a record deal when you're 18
years old and you're a one-hit wonder
you you're not going to get there these
are these are just mythology it's just
and here's the last one and the worst
one of all
that the average millionaire the typical
person that's wealthy in america
inherited their money
and it's simply not true
uh out of the
10 000 millionaires that we interviewed
for the ramsey millionaire study and it
really bears out in who we talk to here
on the air as well
79
of those that we interviewed received
zero inheritance
five percent received
a very small inheritance like five
thousand dollars from their grandmother
which does not make you a millionaire
okay
um
and another five percent like our last
caller received some money after they
were already millionaires
last caller had a four million dollar
net worth and last year got 55 000 which
was a substantial amount of money but it
was after they were already it didn't
cause that if they'd had gotten a
million dollars last year it didn't
cause it they already had a three
million dollar net worth and so they
didn't become millionaires because of
that so here's the point the point is
you can do it
you can do it so five percent
you know small in here it's five percent
after and 79 nothing that's 89 so that's
9 out of 10 millionaires that's almost
all of them did not become millionaires
because they inherited their money so
there's some thanksgiving dinner trivia
for those of you when you're home with
your left wing family
that thinks that the only way you become
wealthy is liberal policies because
wealth must be redistributed
because it's not fair to the little man
9 out of 10 millionaires are little man
this is the best system ever in the
history of mankind
literally
to become a millionaire today
in america today with all of its
problems and all of its isms and all of
its systemic problems that are really
there
there's so much stinking opportunity out
there if you will just pay attention
we can get you there yeah and i love
hearing the stories of the debt-free
screams on the stage they say dave we
paid off our house and they whispered to
you when you meet them and they say oh
and we're we're everyday millionaires
we're babysit millionaires too dave it's
amazing and they always do whisper it
they don't they don't cheer that one
it's like it's feels like a mammal brag
it is a humble breath but because they
it's weird
because it's it's
we have a culture that
tells you to go be successful and then
curses you when you are
and then don't talk about it don't tell
anyone yeah because
you should be ashamed of yourself well
this hour we're encouraging humble brags
yes we are we want to let people know
yes we are because i want people to have
hope that they can do it too
that's the thing can you do it too yes
you can bill is with us in dayton ohio
bill what is your net worth
hey dave i'm at 1.46 million
cool give me a little break down on that
by category
i've got about i guess 900 000 in
between my iras and tsp
uh i've got a home worth about 290
000
cash about 250 000 and then
a couple cars
okay very cool how old are you
55. good good and how much of this did
you inherit
uh exactly zero okay exactly not a penny
more not a penny less and what's been
your best year best your working income
worst year working income
uh so
i guess when i when i first got in the
military i was making about 17 000 a
year
got you know the two to three thousand
increases every year with promotion or
whatever and uh
now i'm up about 198 000 so it averages
out to about 80 000 a year gotcha cool
thank you for your service very cool
which branch are you in
uh air for i was in the air force active
duty and then i retired and i'm a
civilian working for the air force ah
okay cool what's your degree and do you
have a four-year degree
i do i was a industrial distribution
major in the aerospace uh um
sciences for my master's cool and your
um
your gpa
i was probably a 3.2 for undergrad and
probably a 3.8 for graduate yeah that's
about normal okay good for you
so you did all of this as a military guy
your wife work outside the home
uh well so
that was one of those things you know
you have to be with somebody who matches
your
your saving patterns and i was not
married to someone who did that so
i started making more money after we
split ah okay all right so the pictures
we got of of you or with your kids i was
trying to look down in the youtube
picture okay all right yeah very cool
good for you yeah those are my kids so
yeah as a matter of fact my son just
graduated with his master's last year
and he's now a financial planner working
for a new no fee company in the dc area
very cool
very cool so uh bill
again i had a military on a little guy a
little bit earlier do you think you
could talk to the young service guys and
tell them it can be done
oh definitely um so the first thing you
have to do is just you know pay yourself
first put that money away in
ira or some savings
vehicle and just pretend it's not even
there yeah and then pay yourself with
every pay raise and uh and then leave
live you know below your means yeah it's
it's it's sounds like it sounds like
you've avoided that like the plague
oh well you know i i did the thing for
quite a few years where you're moving
credit card bounces around and you know
it was just ridiculous and when i
finally found your program um
oh i don't know about 15 years ago it
woke me up and i've lived by it ever
since and
it's brought me where i am now very cool
proud of you bill thank you again for
your service and thanks for calling in
dude you're a financial hero you did it
you became a millionaire it sounds like
he put these investments on autopilot no
pun intended
[Laughter]
900 000.
nice catch george he's just an
impressive guy so we got a 51 year old
37 39 54 55 so no number 80
number number 27
right and gpas were 3.0 3.8 3.4 3.2
the net worths were 3 million 1.1 1.1 4
million and 1.46 these ones we took on
the day
and so you see the patterns evolve
and the patterns are
they're repeatable we see them all the
time we don't set these calls up folks
we don't tell them what they have to say
we want to find out what's really going
on
but you really can't break statistical
averages they show up yeah and there's a
lot of themes here they lived on less
than they made they invested
consistently over time they got out of
debt they paid off their house and all
of a sudden you look at the numbers in
the mix and you go oh my gosh i'm a
millionaire i did
well happy thanksgiving everybody happy
thanksgiving we hope this inspires you
to go be a baby steps millionaire that's
your next goal we want you to do it
george happy thanksgiving you as well
dave james and kelly and austin in the
booth thanks guys well done bobby all of
you happy thanksgiving that puts this
hour of the ramsay show in the books
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
you